Are there signs of copper toxicity?
I heard that we should be using copper pans,
but you said you don't agree.
That's right.
I have said it in other questions,
answering other people's questions in the past
that I don't agree with using copper bracelets
and copper pans and copper cookware.
And there's a lot of, yeah, quote unquote,
nutritional counselors that are out there,
an Instagram and TikTok and Facebook
that quite frankly, I tell you wrong information.
This would be one of them
that we should be using more copper.
Copper is good for us.
So use copper pans.
Well, copper is a necessary nutrient for us
because copper helps with growth and cell turnover.
But you get your copper through your food.
So your source of copper would not be elemental copper
in your copper pans or your copper pipes.
That's basically a toxic heavy metal.
Secondly, cancer patients in general
don't want to be taking multiple vitamins
that have copper or minerals that have copper.
Even if they're a good source of copper,
shouldn't be taking anything that's a bad source of anything.
But even then say you're taking a good source double bonded
to an amino acid copper, should I be taking that?
Well, not as a cancer patient
because what does copper do?
Copper helps stimulate growth,
so you shouldn't be taking that.
And then also, even if you didn't have cancer
for the most part,
most people are getting excess copper
and end up with copper toxicity.
If you remember under your genetic report,
we looked at your copper genes.
People that have defects on your copper carrying genes
could even have more issues with copper.
Copper toxicity is common.
What could be signs of copper toxicity?
The most common would be headaches, fatigue,
just nausea, and typically it's gonna be a low dose
copper toxicity that this person have.
You could end up with arthritis,
rheumatoid arthritis,
gaudy arthritis, as a copper toxicity sign.
And then if you start taking zinc, what rule of thumb?
If you start taking zinc and you feel sick,
that's not an uncommon thing
because zinc will push out excess copper,
excess especially excess elemental copper,
it'll push it out in your cells.
If you feel sick, typically it's like a headache
after taking zinc, it's a sign that you have copper toxicity,
that you'll have to take some vitamin C to bind it.
So make sure you contact me.
If you are taking zinc and you don't say,
well, every time I take zinc, I do feel sick.
I don't know, I thought I was just
trying to send sensitivity to zinc.
No, it's that you have a copper toxicity.
So you gotta go slow to help detox the copper.
So how would a person detox copper?
It would be by taking zinc,
but you'd also have to take a binder
or a key later with it, vitamin C does keylate copper well,
though we don't want excess vitamin C as cancer patient
for its antioxidant purposes,
but using a key later to bind that copper
is a good thing to do,
otherwise it could just circulate and cause more issues.
That would say the same thing that question about copper toxicity
and using copper pans,
you could say the same thing about using cast iron pans.
I'm not against using cast iron pans,
but certainly that's not a source of iron.
People will post that and other Instagram posts.
Use cast iron pans, that's how you get your iron.
I know, that's elemental iron.
You don't get your iron by chewing on metal bars.
You know, you get your iron from your food.
So from organ meat, from vegetables,
you don't get your minerals from elemental sources.
Those are toxic sources, so that's not how we get our minerals.